a lot of unhappiness comes about in this
world because we can't let other people
know what we mean clearly enough one of
the philosophers who can help us with
our communication problems is Ludovic
fit can steam he was a recluse he had a
stutter paused for ages in the middle of
his sentences and had a habit of
storming out if he didn't like what
people were saying it was weirdly the
ideal background for someone intent on
studying how easily communication
between people goes wrong Ludwig
Wittgenstein was born in Vienna in 1889
the youngest child of a wealthy highly
cultured but domineering steel magnate
three of Ludwig's four brothers took
their own lives and Ludwig himself was
frequently troubled by suicidal thoughts
when he was young he was interested in
engineering after studying at Cambridge
his father died and he inherited a lot
of money he gave it all away mainly to
his already very rich relatives and went
to live in Spartan solitude in Norway
then he started writing a book published
in 1921 called Tractatus
logico-philosophicus it was a short
beautiful and baffling work the big
question that Vidkun Stein asks in it is
how do human beings manage to
communicate ideas to one another and his
answer which felt revolutionary is that
language works by triggering within us
pictures of how things are in the world
if it can stand thought of this while
reading a newspaper article about a
Paris Court case in which in order to
explain with greater efficacy the
details of an accident that had taken
place at a road junction the court had
arranged for the accident to be
reproduced visually using model cars and
pedestrians it was a Eureka moment in
Vidkun Stein's view words enable us to
make pictures of facts to say the palm
tree is by the shore paints a rapid
sketch that like the model lets another
person see the situation in their mind
and understand we're constantly swapping
pictures between us but the Paris court
needed to resort to an actual model for
a very important reason because on the
whole we're very
managing to make good pictures in the
minds of others communication typically
goes wrong because other people have as
we put it the wrong picture of what
we're meaning it can take an age for two
people to realize divergences over quite
basic things problems of communication
typically start because we don't have a
clear and accurate enough picture of
what we mean in our own heads we say
quite meaningless or muddled or
unalloyed Finn's which therefore can go
nowhere in the minds of others there's
another danger that we read more meaning
into the words of others than they ever
intended or than is warranted you tell
your partner you had a conversation with
an interesting person at the hotel
reception the picture in your mind is an
innocent one but your partner swiftly
forms a very different impression the
Tractatus is a plea by a very taciturn
silent and precise Austrian philosopher
to speak more carefully and less
impulsively as he famously put it for
fun man expression can the hooba must
munch vegan when he published it Vidkun
Stein thought somewhat grandly that the
Tractatus was the last work of
philosophy that would ever need to be
written so he looked around for how to
fill the rest of his life he turned to
architecture and spent a couple of years
designing a house for his sister in
Vienna he spent ages getting the door
handles and the radiators right very
late on in the project he could
increasingly bothered about the ceiling
in one of the rooms and came to the
conclusion that it was too low at
immense inconvenience to everyone he
insisted on having it raised by three
centimeters it made all the difference
he thought then in 1929 Vidkun Stein
suddenly returned to Cambridge and to
philosophy because he realized he'd had
some new things to say about language
and communication and so he began to
write a second book published
posthumously and that we now know as
philosophical investigations instead of
thinking that language is only just
about pictures he developed the idea
that language is like a kind of tool
that we use to play different games
which doesn't literally mean games more
patterns of intentions so if a parent
says to a frightened child don't worry
everything is going to be fine they
can't know it really we'll be fine
they aren't playing the rational
prediction from available facts game
they're playing another game the words
as an instrument of comfort and security
game VidCon signs point is that all
kinds of misunderstandings arise when we
don't see which kind of games someone is
involved in if one's partner says you
never help me you're so unreliable the
natural inclination might be to hear
this as a part of a stating the facts
game like saying the Battle of Waterloo
was in 1815 so one might respond by
citing facts about how actually you got
the car insurance yesterday and you
bought some vegetables at lunch time too
but actually this person is involved in
a different language game they're using
words not to capture facts they're
playing the help and reassurance game so
in the language game they're involved in
you never help means I want you to be
more nurturing working out the game in
question is fit constrain realized key
to good communication in the
philosophical investigations VidCon
Stein also wanted to draw attention to
how much of our self understanding
depends on the words of others on
languages that have developed publicly
and communally over many centuries long
before we're born for example on Sunday
afternoon I might fall prey to a worried
confused mood as I think about the week
ahead and everything I've got to do my
ability to know this very private side
of myself and to help others know me
will be hugely enhanced if I have to
hand a word that's been around awhile
angst a word which was helpfully
formulated by the philosopher
Kierkegaard in 19th century Copenhagen
words like angst or also nostalgia
melancholy or ambivalent and many others
help us to name elusive areas of our own
experience language is a public tool for
the understanding of private life the
richness of the language were exposed to
is therefore really important to our
self-knowledge reading many books gives
us tools with which to help to know who
we are though a lot of it contains
philosophy is deeply complicated its
underpinned by a desire always to be
helpful the task of philosophy said
Wittgenstein is to show the fly the way
out of the fly bottle the particular fly
bottle he was
interested in was language and before
his death from cancer in 1951 he managed
to let out for us a lot of word flies
usefully for us all